-You've had such
an eclectic career.
Are there certain roles
that you get approached for
more than others?
-Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, people --
You know, people know
"The Devil Wears Prada."
-Yeah.
-Which is, you know,
a great film.
Or "The Hunger Games"
or "The Lovely Bones,"
which is very disturbing,
you know.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah, there's a lot.
"Easy A," too, is one.
-Oh, that's nice.
-Yeah, yeah.
So, it's nice, yeah.
-You -- It kind of
came out of nowhere.
Sam Rockwell was hosting "SNL."
-Oh, my God, yeah.
-And Pete Davidson did a rap
about you called "Tucci Gang."
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's -- there's Sam as you.
-Yeah.
-With Pete Davidson.
And there -- there's Sam.
-Yeah.
-So, uh, now obviously,
this must have been --
it was unexpected for me.
It must have been completely
unexpected for you.
-I was completely shocked.
My publicist called, said,
"They need you to do an image
or say something
for, you know,
'Saturday Night Live.'"
And I was like, "What is it?
I don't know what you're
talking about," you know.
And -- I knew what
"Saturday Night Live" was.
I mean, yeah, I did, yeah.
But once you -- you know,
I stopped watching it
once you left.
-Thank you.
-Yeah. Um...uh...
[ Laughter ]
And Sam I've known
for a really long time.
-Yeah.
-So, anyway, I said,
"Yeah, sure."
And they told me what they --
and then I saw what they did.
-Yeah.
-And of course, I didn't know
the genesis, I didn't know
what it was based on.
So my children
had to explain to me
what it was and showed me
the video.
I was like, "Oh, wow,
that's good."
-Right.
-Yeah.
So, it's brilliant,
and I was very flattered.
-And was this something that --
I can only imagine
how many people --
You know, when somebody --
when you see something
that is about your friends,
so many people must have
texted you and reached out
and said, "Have you seen it?"
-Oh, yeah. No, they were
flipped out by it.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I mean, I was, too.
I mean, I was
completely shocked.
-It is wonderful
that your children
had to explain it to you.
I think that's --
-Yes, I know, I know, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
-I'm looking forward
to that part of my life
where I can stop trying to have
any connection to pop culture,
and they can just --
-Oh, yeah.
They just tell you everything.
-Yeah. Oh.
-And then you go, "Well,
how do you get it --"
"Oh, just give it to me."
[ Laughter ]
-You're a cook as well.
-Yeah, I like to cook.
-Do your children like
your cooking?
-Yeah, they do, yes.
-That's great.
-And the two who are at
university now are quite sad,
because they don't have
the cooking.
-Yeah.
-So, when they come home,
I make sure to make as much
stuff as possible.
You just make sauces
or something
to give them
so they can take it home.
-Oh, that's very kind.
That's very kind and helpful.
And you've had
a couple of cookbooks.
-I have. I put one
together a long time ago
that my parents did with
an Italian chef,
Gianni Scappin.
And then my wife and I did one
a few years ago together, yeah.
-Was that a fun process,
building together the recipes
for a cookbook?
-It is. It's fun.
But it is such hard work.
It's incredibly hard work
to sort of
piece them all together.
Because you have to have
a hundred recipes.
-Yeah.
-Really,
to have a real cookbook.
And then the testing of them
will take you a year.
-Really?
-At least a year.
-And how is your wife
as a collaborator?
-Oh, she's amazing.
Well, she's a literary agent.
-Oh, wonderful.
-But, so, she's incredible.
And she's a great cook, too.
-And what is the cookbook
that you did with her called?
-It's called "The Tucci Table."
-Oh, that's very good.
-Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
She said, "Well, we could
call it 'Tucci and Friend'
or something."
[ Laughter ]
She goes, "Because you have
one friend.
Let's face it," you know.
[ Laughter ]
And -- but it's basically
what we would cook
throughout a year.
-Yeah.
-For your friends
and your family.
-That's great.
"Table for Tucci"?
-"Table for Tucci."
-You could do that next time.
-There you go, yeah.
-Now you gotta do a third book.
-Thank you. Thank you. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks so much for being here.
-Thank you.
-It's really a pleasure
to speak to you.
-Thanks a lot.